[Music]
one of the legendary figures of
Hollywood died this week Robert Evans
was a movie producer and studio chief
with credits that includes some of the
best love films of all time through the
years his exploits both personal and
professional brought him notoriety well
beyond the studio lots I'm gonna make
him an offer again with you as head of
the studio behind the Godfather Robert
Evans seemed to have a magic touch in
the late 1960s and early 70s he had a
remarkable run of hits overseeing
productions like love story Rosemary's
Baby The Odd Couple and True Grit just
to name a few Evans who died this week
at the age of 89 was a classic himself
Robert Evans was almost the stereotype
the cliche the epitome of this hotshot
Hollywood producer he had a glamorous
lifestyle he had good looks ridiculous
huge sunglasses he was known for being a
ladies man is known for doing more than
his share of drugs that got him into
trouble a few times and he also produced
some of the most famous movies some of
the most beloved movies of his era while
trying to make it as an actor Evans cast
mates in The Sun Also Rises begged 20th
Century Fox had Darryl zanuck to fire it
instead zanuck declared the kid stays in
the picture a phrase that eventually
became the title of Evans 1994
autobiography when Evans acting career
dried up he reinvented himself as a
producer and talked his way into the job
of studio chief at Paramount Pictures
afternoon my name is Robert Evans and
I'm senior vice president of Paramount
Pictures Evans tabloid ready life got
nearly as much attention as his films
this perpetually tan evans dated and
married some of the industry's most
glamorous women including his love story
star Ali MacGraw he was married and
divorced seven times by the mid-1970s he
left his studio position at Paramount to
focus on produce
hits including Chinatown an urban cowboy
while his influence waned over the years
he continued to work and saw something
of a popular resurgence in 2002 but this
time he was the subject a film
documentary based on his autobiography
which Evans narrated himself goodbye 17
hello Andes here I come
that led to a Comedy Central animated
series kid notorious based on his life I
know you that a movie executive was the
subject of such projects speaks to the
place
Evans held in popular culture Robert
Evans
really was kind of the last of a certain
breed of producer you know in the 30s
and 40s and 50s producers were really
dominant they were the famous ones and
Robert Evans was that kind of producer
he was larger than life he was famous he
was infamous in a lot of cases and there
really aren't people like that today the
book is worth reading the documentary is
worth seeing in the audio book just the
way he tracks it is it's crazy I think
to know him only through his wives
none of the marriages were longer than
three years yes some call that dating
that's an it was nice